hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with the match Fabiano Khurana vs. max
in wasilla gravity on who is currently
in the top four so he is he is in the
playoffs but he still needs to remain in
the top four and Maxime holograph
he needs the beat Fabiana and also win
the next next match to qualify for the
top four in this tournament to go into
the knockout stage of the tournament and
of course Fabi will try everything he
can to prevent that so in Game one Fabi
with the white pieces opens with d4 and
Maxime still sticks to his love with d4
d5 c4 and c6 so the Slav defense is on
the board probably said ok this is this
is an online tournament yes it is a
pretty big deal there's a lot of money
involved and you know these are the
absolute top elite players in the world
but if I don't experiment now when am I
going to do so so he sticks with the
Slav we have Knight to f3 and Knight to
f6 now we have III by Fabi and Bishop to
f5 again preparing to close the cage
with East 6 we have Knight to c3 and
ecigs now and the Knights to h4 going
after the bishop with Bishop to e4 and
now f3 pushing back the Bishop all the
way to g6 and now Queen b3 going after
the b7 pawn you can always recap you can
always capture on g6 so Queen c7 maxime
defense and the bishop to d2 now Fabi
continues development and Maxime does
the same Bishop e7 prepares castles and
C captures on d5 so a trade in the
center captures captures and only now
Fabi captures on g6 with Knight captures
H captures and a queenside castle by
Fabi we have a 6 not allowing the
Knights to be 5 for white also preparing
b5 in the future as a whitey did Castle
queenside so you might want to start
attacking there and King to be 1 now
just unpinning the knight can now move
and night the c6 and here rook to see
one now x-raying that Queen on c7 and
rook to b8 now and the disposition has
been reached and most often played moves
are nice to a foreign g3 here but the
move Bobby played Bishop to d3 is a new
move so already as a move 15 we have a
completely new game so the h2 pawn is
basically free for grabs so Maxime goes
for it but we have grouped characters
and age too but now it's Fabi who has
the open H file for you know just to use
for his attacks as the Brooks has
already been played on b8 so black
cannot castle and you might have some
problems there but Mac seem very
confident that he will be able to do
this we have Knight to e2 and now
already there might be some threat
threats involved for example if the
Queen moves somewhere then maybe Rock a
person ceases expelled by Queen captures
here is an idea so you constantly have
to keep an eye on ideas like captures
and maybe closing up the queen with the
g3 so that to make sure nothing like
that happens Maxime just trades rook a
person h1 we have rook captures and now
just b5 and you now will have to worry
about rook to e8 at some point but now
for the moment it's not a problem so
first Fabi just strikes in the center
with E 4 and now comes Queen to b6
putting pressure on the d4 pawn but now
Queen to d1 bye-bye Fabi saying that
okay there's a nice juicy d4 pawn for
you but if if Maxime actually went for
the pawn then you get rook h8 check and
now there's a problem because you either
start giving material if you block with
the bishop then there should be 4 is
deadly if you block with the night you
of course lose it and if King here then
you just capture here and after Queen
captures it's then a free night so of
course Maxime doesn't grab the pawn we
have nights the b4 now offers a trade of
bishops and Bishop captures on before we
have Bishop after Sun before and now
comes C 5 I meant to say offers a trade
for Bishop for a knight
so e 5 pushing back the night and the
Knight to d7 now we have F for
strengthening that Center and night the
f8 now I will be useful guarding against
that rock to a trait idea and here Fabi
goes for g4 at some point he wants to
bust open the position with f5 and
Bishop back to e7 now we have Knight the
g3 with more support for f5 and now rook
the c8 and now Maxine will shift the
attention of of the rook and the Queen
hopefully to the C file we have looked
the 88 now not allowing this night to
move and now King to d8
here Maxime will try and shift his king
over to the to the Queen side we have
Bishop the c2 and now comes a f5 and not
allowing a white to push a 5 Maxime does
it himself so he captures an f6 unperson
we have G captures an f6 and now Bishop
characters and g6 so winning back his
pawn and the knight of course cannot
capture as it's been talking to c7 now
there is the threat of knife characters
so Bishop back to c2 and now comes King
to be 8 and now the king is nicely
nicely put away on the Queen side a very
safe there and night to eat you now
again with some defense of the d4 and
and f4 pawns and though you can also
shoot the Knight to c3 if needed so
Queen to c7 now if the Queen moves you
you will have a lot of pressure here on
the c2 Bishop and Fabi opens up the
position with a 4 and here maxime
decides the capture it before also is
perhaps possible but he doesn't go for
it then perhaps a6 will be weak after
the Queen comes to d3 so he decides to
capture it and after Bishop captures he
goes for Knight to d7 now he offers a
trade of rooks and Fabi declines with
rook to h7 now putting pressure on the
bishop we have night the b6 now going
after the dish up here ending out Bishop
back to b3 and the Queen to d6 now so
the bishop is nicely defended with Queen
to d3 Fabi goes after the a6 pawn and
now Knight to c4
now basically Maxime says I either have
a beautiful office for my knight here or
you have to trade your Bishop for night
here which Fabi does he doesn't
appreciate this night being here and now
rook captures on c4 again blocking the
Queen's attack of the of the a sex pawn
but okay the the black Queen defends it
for the moment we have Quinta III and
now with ideas of f5 and then there
would be some dangers about capturing
the the bishop on e7 so rook the c7
defending the bishop and now comes
Knight to c3
bringing the night into the game we have
rook the b7 now shifting the attack over
to the b-pawn and here Fabi goes for f5
and this is where I things really start
to get interesting here Maxime has the
option of
Queen before put some pressure on the BT
upon so maybe this would force Fabi to
go back with the rook or he can do it
captures on f5 which he did in the game
father recaptured and now bash up the d8
he decided to offer a trade of rooks and
now getting his Queen to b4 and going
for four this attack is probably a bit
better than going for this trade because
after Fabi captured the King captures in
Knight a for the night appears to be
better than the bishop tonight we'll
have a nice outpost here on c5 and well
it's just not clear how black will
attack the white king whereas white has
some very clear ideas on how you will
attack if you try and prevent it with
something like Bishop here then it's
possible but then the Queen comes here
and you might you might have some issues
here the white King will improve his
position very quickly and it might be a
completely walking opponent game for for
black so instead Kings to a7 getting out
of any any checks but now Queen to ea8
and it's again very hard to find a move
Bishop to c7 but now Knight the c5 and
again it's it's black to move but
they're there simply aren't all that
many moves for example if you try just
to waste a move Queen f7 wins the game
now you either go to a8 and you get made
at Queen b7 mate or after let's say
something like Queen Queen to have 7 you
go brush up the c7 but then it is just
nice to e6 with a double attack here and
here as the night now blocks the Queen's
defense of the of the point here so once
you defend Queen captures here it gets a
pass pawn and of course a completely
winning game so after Knight c5 maxime
tried a different idea he has to make a
move although it's very hard to find one
Bishop to d8 would would still be would
still be playable however a Maxine
played Queen to f4 he decided to go for
some counter attacking ideas now the
point is under attack you might have to
worry about Queen to f1 check the d4
pawn is under attack
however this loses the game completely
and feel free to pause the video and
find out how Bobby found it or of may
may not have found it but you know you
find it while it was the video so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting that there
is a mate
on b7 and for those who just want to
enjoy the show its Queen to c8 now
stopping Queen captures on f5 with Czech
but also threatening Queen b7 mate and
here the bishop and Queen are well
basically on dark squares you cannot
reach b7 doesn't matter how hard you try
so here Maxime tried Queen to f1 check
with King to a2 and now Queen to c4
check Fabi just play King to a3 and now
the problem is that the d3 square is
covered by the knight so there is no
check here and the only other way at the
defendant would be to go to b5 but it
was in this position unmoved 47 death
and Maxie marshal Agra resigned the game
and Game one of their match goes to Fabi
so here only way to defend this Queen b5
to defend maid button Queen captures on
c7 check your down a piece and of course
black is completely lost
sure really really a wild game and
Maxime is still sticking to his Slav and
he's now down one point and if he
doesn't get back into the match and beat
Fabi
he is not coming to playoffs and he will
be out of the tournament sure that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to once again thank Abdul Abdul
Moxon Oh Rajee a Karsten Curtin Stephen
Atkinson Chris Antley and Martin Fisher
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos Sharon thank all for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the magnets Invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and I will be
announcing the first guest of my podcast
very soon see you soon guys